i think what they're doing right now is
getting us super acquainted to
understanding the rules and the
definitions that way
when the rules are being broken we
understand the stakes and we could
follow what the hell is going on in this
movie because because of the fact of how
crazy all this is going to be this is
all gonna be nuts and it is all gonna be
connected and i think it's already
connected they're just not making it as
obvious because it's not as simple i'm
here to defend marvel
[Music]
what's going on there reject nation greg
and john here today what we're going to
talk about today
might seem pointless to some yet uh i i
don't think it is pointless especially
when i go online and i i see this being
kind of a common complaint for some this
may be already like an obvious answer
for others i i guess i'll i'll try to
offer up a glimmer of hope if that's
what you're looking for i don't really
know what we're talking about today is
is marvel's phase four has it been
directionless i am often hearing that
some people are feeling about marvel
phase four it makes sense to me why some
people might actually feel that way yet
i don't actually agree with it being
directionless i think there's kind of a
fascinating point that we don't know
where exactly the mcu is headed we have
our ideas of where it could be going
based off comics and such and a bunch of
clues that have been given from the
shows and movies but i wouldn't call it
directionless so before we hop into this
if you guys can leave a like that'd be
very much appreciated all right so
looking through marvel phase four
there's been a lot that has been
introduced you know like starting with
one division start getting a lot more
sorcery abilities and a lot more
supernatural elements with things like
moon knight and then you have things
that seem like they might be the biggest
game changers for the mcu hands down you
know you had like loki and then the
timelines breaking apart with uh he who
remains at the very end of it he had the
multiverse with spider-man no way home
and then you had dr strange and the
multiverse of madness and i think as
viewers what we're so used to
with marvel for the infinity saga is
things just feeling you know very
connected in a very obvious way phase
one through three which i find funny
when you think about it because the
whole thing was leading up to the fight
with thanos getting the infinity stones
it's something really easy to like wrap
your head around it's really like
physical really clear through a line
that we're building up to a big baddie
by the end of it and we know who the big
baddie is but what's funny to me is how
joss whedon just threw that thanos cameo
in there just for fun and didn't had no
intention of it like building into what
it became but that's what it is and i
feel like that's really
set our expectations for the marvel
cinematic universe going forward so with
this one i can actually see why people
feel like it's maybe not connecting so
much because they're introducing all
kinds of elements yet
the movies and shows are not really
going out of their ways other than like
doctor strange connecting to wanda's
story in wanda vision a lot of the
movies are not seemingly referencing the
events of prior installments in phase
four and going because of this thing
that happened in phase four now this is
happening in our movie you even had to
have kevin feige at the premiere of
doctor strange too say because of the
events of loki what loki and silvi did
that allowed the events of spider-man no
way home to happen and the events of
doctor strange multiverse of madness to
happen but the movies don't say that
while the movies are not maybe going out
of their ways to to really point and go
see look
look hey
remember this guy i think it's because
on the multiverse
is something so
vast and dense and complex and they're
bringing so much from the comics into
the fray because what did we get with
loki we had timelines and then you have
multiverse and then doctor strange too
introduced what incursion events and
then with eternals you have gods you
know
even godlier gods yeah you have these
cosmic entities right now what i think
marvel's doing i think they are having a
through line the common belief is that
they're building up to avengers secret
war i could see that happening i could
see that being like the big ultimate
cataclysmic event i believe the comic
run my god i should have really done a
refresher on this i read the comics
before one division came out and my
comic retention memory in detail is not
the strongest so correct me on anything
i get wrong here because it was like the
secret wars in the 80s and then there
was like 2015 but the one before the
2015 run was i believe it's a comic
called out of time i think it's called
out of time and i think that's what
they're building to first which has like
a new group of illuminati members from
earth616 there's incursions happening
and they're trying to figure out how to
save their universe while dealing with
incursions in the multiverse that
eventually segues in to secret wars i
feel like that's where we're going first
as maybe like the next avengers 5 movie
with everything that's been set up in
place what i think is cool what the mcu
has been doing is they've been allowing
more often than not sometimes you get
things like a black widow i don't really
feel like the unique voice of the
director in that movie phase one through
three had a lot of different genres it
did feel more like marvel's directing
this movie than it is like the own
director's voice and i feel like you
hear like that more often close y'all's
eternals are like close movies sam
raimi's multiverse madness felt like sam
raimi behind the camera the shows really
feel like the director's medium way more
than just marvel committee granted
marvel's hands
[Music]
i think what they're doing is something
that'll kind of creep up on us in a way
that may not be so obvious is that by
the time we get that crossover event
what you're seeing is a battle for a lot
of different authorities happening right
now you have like everything with the
tva introduced there you have kang who's
had his own multiversal war and now
king's back and he's probably gonna want
to dominate earth 616. situations with
incursions set up by clia at the end of
multiverse of madness you have eternals
the gods you know like this is something
where i think we are building two secret
wars but i feel like by the time we get
there that's when we're gonna see how
it's all connected as opposed to telling
you beforehand how it's all connected if
that makes sense yeah that's a really
good point i feel like they still want
to be able to surprise us and it's only
gotten harder and two i feel like if you
think back on the original phases of
marvel we now have the benefit of 2020
hindsight in that that was a three-phase
build up to thanos so i don't expect the
same kind of cataclysmic culmination out
of phase four necessarily and yeah i
mean we have had phase four introduce a
lot of gods and a lot of new characters
and a lot of committees that try to
oversee but not necessarily interrupt
what is happening on earth or whatever
realm is subject to the story the
pandemic probably did figure in koi said
something that's always stuck in my mind
of like i think they had a five or ten
year plan that got interrupted by the
pandemic and now they're figuring out
probably a new 10-year plan but i still
feel like yeah it's a first phase of
what's to come even though it's phase
four even though it's continuing out of
what we know already they're still doing
a lot of setup and there's still you
know i think a lateral motion that can
happen there and yeah i think a lot of
us are a little taken aback and i feel
like this is probably due to the
pandemic that there aren't as many
direct acknowledgments and direct
crossovers especially with things like
loki and they've had to remix these
films so how it appears to me is more
like yeah they might have had to kind of
hamper some of that huge
interconnectivity given the uncertainty
of just the world right now but at the
same time yeah we have already
speculation of secret wars coming down
the pike and i feel like they are well
aware of that too and they probably want
to make us you know focus on a whole
array of other things before getting
there and so yeah while phase 4 doesn't
necessarily feel like it has a direct
end point it's trying to get to it has
had a lot of very consistent themes and
character dynamics that it's been
establishing thus far at least and i
think it'll be interesting to see how
marvel changes how its phases work and
operate moving forward because the first
three phases are good to start with
they're kind of crisp and contained you
know they're five or six movies maybe a
little bit more than that but a
culminating in some kind of avengers
thing i feel like we could see a change
to that moving forward because they also
have to make us not get too used to like
okay there will be five or six movies
and then the avengers there'll be five
or six movies in the avengers so yeah
i'm curious to see how
they uh emboldened the interconnectivity
of the shows and films moving forward
they did stress that at you know the the
unveiling of a lot of these shows and it
hasn't played out in such a connected
way as they suggested so i feel like
that's something that they want to do i
feel like they just haven't been able to
do it just yet well i think it is all
connected we just don't
see it as clearly yet you know like the
shang chi post credit scene had captain
marvel in it and the marvel's is
probably gonna factor in heavily to
everything we're talking about right now
and you know and then we got secret
invasion coming up because i think
there's so much information like the
comics enough are difficult to keep up
with that
for bringing this to movies you have to
kind of take this one step at a time so
that way we can understand these
definitions better so that way when
things start running into chaos we kind
of understand what the chaos is as
opposed to there's a whole bunch of
mumbo-jumbo words being thrown around i
don't quite get the differences between
incursions timelines and multiverses i
think that the first three phases were
so much about saving the universe and i
think what we're building to is saving
the multiverse you know we got king the
conqueror coming back for ant-man
quantum mania i think the obvious thing
a lot of people are speculating on is
that kang would be
the big multiversal baddie especially
the way loki set the events and
considering who kang is but if we are
really headed down this path i am
curious to know if dr doom will actually
be the big baddie when it comes to the
multiversal threat it would be cool if
like we think we're getting kang to be
the big baddie but we're really building
to is doctor doom who has like a mastery
on the two things that are being
introduced heavily right now in the mcu
which is magic and science fiction crap
cosmos like there's so much things that
dr doom is the master of and when it
came to secret wars he was the big
baddie of it he ended up taking like
bits and pieces of the multiverse
creating his own world battle world i
think is what it's called that's where
the big
crossover event happened which got a new
future for marvel comics moving forward
after secret wars was a whole mix of
things so i think what they're doing
right now is getting a super acquainted
to understanding the rules and the
definitions that way
when the rules are being broken we
understand the stakes and we could
follow what the hell is going on in this
movie because because of the fact of how
crazy all this is going to be this is
all going to be nuts and it is all gonna
be connected and i think it's already
connected they're just not making it as
obvious because it's not as simple even
if they borrow from secret wars i think
that's all it's gonna be i think they'll
really borrow from it civil war was very
different in the comics than it was in
the movies the infinity saga very
different too you know they might be
borrowing like the the main idea but i
think what they're they're um
streamlining some of it to make it more
digestible for the average audience
member i'm here to defend marvel i get
that paycheck you gotta marvel's gotta
pay me my money that's right they need
they need your help don't hold out hope
guys just stop don't know it's all gonna
make sense it'll it'll connect you'll
get your cameos i promise all cameos are
coming get your iron man 2 level of
inter crossover guys anyway what do you
guys think
i'll talk with you guys soon